today on our show man star wars Civil
War's gonna just add a whole lot more
all next here on fat man I'm Batman
welcome to fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith
mark barnard we're here to talk [ __ ]
look all we're gonna tell you things are
going on in the world lunch pop and
culture we got both here along and
culture not like the country-and-western
and s11 I tried to rock it on this young
audience cuz you don't know from all
kinds hear pop ankle that's what's next
- they're gonna remake the Blues
Brothers with all women like
ghostbusters now they're good listening
I'm so like I'm from New England just
like they're doing Ghostbusters all-lady
cast when we do Blues Brothers all
ladies soul sisters like that came off
the table who said you saw the moment of
inspiration mark barnard sweat coming
off my head like a football player
you're right a cold yeah I always fit
myself a writer but you you're right
let's talk about this movie that needs a
little help man we here at fat man I'm
Batman we believe in helping the
underdog and there's a movie that's
worth your time that you might have
missed this holiday season you could
have just it just flown right over your
head see it if you can
yeah find it somewhere it's called Star
Wars The Force awakens there's yet
another Star Wars story this
[ __ ] won't leave the news as we
speak it's passing avatar as the highest
domestic a mystic yes roasting
international it's still got a ways to
go Oh Charlie yeah that's the thing it's
already hit this one like you're try if
you were trying to climb Everest there a
base not base camp there half where or
that yeah they're like the Hillary stuck
where everybody else dies okay
and so far they're alive they're like we
got plenty to do - we need I was sitting
there gone like wow man what a way to
describe it but it's called the Hillary
was the Hillary step where Sir Edmund
Hillary
died I think on that step and his body
still buried because you can't it turns
out bring bodies down from Everest and
he was the first one yeah I think he was
yeah died on that's the mountain he
chose to talk
step for me I'm so winded
all right so they've reached the Sir
Edmund Hillary level of the box office
but not this cell crown not the summit
and maybe that's how some people out
there still like yeah well I'm telling
you minute whoever writes for Forbes
like I ain't like you know not urging
for somebody to lose job but like
anybody who wrote I don't know if this
movies actually gonna make that much
money yes and writes for box office
reports needs to be looked at social
stuff direct I mean there's a Better
Homes and garden magazine I'm sure he'd
be great at my mom could have predicted
this is gonna be the highest grossing
film domestically at least I that's
thing even if you were like you could
make all the time I would have thrown my
dick out there betting like domestics
gonna take the domestic crown and I
don't even think that's throwing your
dick out there not so much you know what
I'm just showing off a boat you even
have to take it out it's like he's not
even showing off a bulge it's indicating
that I'm I enjoy sex and leave it there
but yeah as its here it stands to take
the crown in the box off domestic
box-office chart highest grossing film
in North America of all time yes
how much further doesn't have to go
another billion another avatar I believe
is 2.8 billion and force awakens is now
1.5 billion in right now this recording
I think we're at 18 days max maybe it's
like 16 days or something so and let's
say okay it's arts best days behind it
at this point you know has everyone who
wants to see it want to see it and is
the holiday period now over and is
everyone going back to work these are a
lot of questions once totally oh yes the
answer to all of them is yes but does
that make a difference this movie's
pretty strong even with the chatter
about like is she a Mary Sue or hey this
is an awful lot like another story and
now you know there's you see pockets
people trying to write articles going
like well now we've reconsidered it and
[ __ ] it or whatever but it don't matter
it keeps earning this is a really
satisfying movie and stuff there's a
chance that it there's a chance beyond a
strong chance I'm not even going like
you know what was it one for right is
one
for15 now it's got to get to two aid so
that's another 1.3 billion yet that's it
as it opened in China yet no it's open
in South Korea and is underperforming in
South Korea underperforming yes but over
performing in GEB in Japan
hey South Korea which Korea is that good
then it's the good one get on the stick
man we don't want prequels anymore on a
roll they're just getting the first tron
in North Korea at this point but I mean
here's here's the thing that sort of
amazes me about comparing those two
movies is that Star Wars has 40 years of
built-in sort of fan awareness
absolutely
avatar didn't like avatar was just a
movie that James Cameron dropped into
the world it's true and starts cold I
mean yeah granted we all saw the movie
when it was called Pocahontas right but
still you're right it is kind of like I
made this movie and there were trailers
and we all went to go see it apparently
87 hundred times each and and it's also
like anybody could have done this let me
granted maybe wouldn't do it as good as
makers I'm Jim Cameron but anybody could
have made a movie about blue cats in
space you know and a magic tree
no doesn't want to and a lot of he like
rode my dick about it
it'll get me like and so he's got that
as well to bragging right and it's like
a good time there weren't that many 3d
screens in the country so not that many
theaters could up charge for the 3d
whereas now you could see nothing but 3d
if that's what you wanted to so do you
think Jim Cameron I mean do you think he
like cuz he's owned the top box-office
lot for Mogan it was Titanic first and
then he sold it from himself with Abbott
right do you think he's sweating at all
do you think he gives a [ __ ] or is that
like look I got 18 more avatars money
[ __ ] 2.8 or whatever the hell yeah
Kitty's up the wazoo yeah he's like the
thing about cats they never die Mallett
forever
all right so so yeah but I still think
it's got a shot but it's a long shot at
this point long shot according to box
office prognosticators who don't work
for Forbes basically it's got a gross
like a Dark Knight level like it's got
to make another 1.3 billion which would
be a massive hit already what I mean
considering were like an adventures on
top of this on top is it it's not it's
not showing signs of wearing oh my god
93 million or something last weekend and
granted that was a holiday weekend you
have your holiday multiplier and stuff
but I feel like even still if you don't
like a good start I don't think I'm and
I will not much neck out there maybe
just a little tip when I stick a tip out
the zipper by going I think it's gonna
do it I would not also put it past
Disney to wisely re-release it before
rogue one opens next christmas.this
go to a 2-shot there's there's your
smart money right there like they will
totally double pump this into theaters
just so they get another 30 40 million
at the tip if that gets them there too
it gets him there all right
all right regardless obviously an
over-the-top success and stuff I believe
in JJ I think he's gonna get there but
let's talk about some of the Star Wars
related that's weird
and not like yeah everyone's to this
movie this new Star is force awakens
picture is the one of the most inclusive
pieces of anything ever created by
mankind would you agree I think so
wholly cap there's two ladies in it and
every it feels like every race is
represent at this time and it feels like
like even like Chewie comes off better
like if you count the animal racer so
it's just like it's very inclusive
you know old characters brand new
characters and one yet there's still
this bizarre stumbling block when it
comes to like making the toys yeah most
people know this Rey throw up the
picture of the Monopoly board and
question the Monopoly board here
star wars monopoly now let's hold on
that picture and look at these four
characters you got thin brand-new to the
Star Wars universe
you got kylo Ren also brand
the Star Wars universe now perhaps
you're playing generations here so when
you include young Luke Skywalker from
Return of the Jedi and you also include
Darth Vader now question about this
Darth Vader ain't even really in other
than mashed up Smashing Pumpkins helmet
he's not really in the force awakens
granted this is Star Wars monopoly not
just the force awakens monopoly but you
see four players on that chess board or
on the Monopoly board one of them ain't
even in the movie right we all know that
the main character in the force awakens
is Finn at this point I'm right the
right one yeah I'm looking at fit where
does where's right well where's Princess
Leia for that matter who is also in this
movie an alive yeah dead wait where's
your Rey yeah where is your ray is the
question that people have been asking
especially about the dolls and then
action figures she's been very scared
she's not like a collectible where
you've got it like scavenger toys-r-us
is to find the one race a chase figure
apparently at this point I went into a
Disney Store over Christmas and I saw a
lot of stormtroopers a lot of kylo ren's
but you're right and see there's not a
time man like you've got a hunt to make
the complete set but once again this is
not this is a toy manufacturer gone I
know toys and girls don't buy this so
we're not gonna but it's like come on
you stop saying monopoly you see yeah
this isn't even like like hey man I
don't want to [ __ ] go through the
process of Meghan plastic molds for a
ray doll nobody's gonna buy if that's
you're at those I personally believe
they buy like crazy
this is monopoly yeah you play it with
notch it's not like I'm gonna me and my
dad and my brother and my grandpa are
gonna play monopoly because it's a man's
game because only men like money you
know and humility visual monopoly it was
like a shoe a dog hat genderless an iron
anybody could play Monopoly but now if
you're a girl and you're looking at
stars monopoly you're like right I guess
it's out here's the official statement
from from Hasbro Hasbro had had walked
it back to the bank they tried to the
Star Wars Monopoly game was released in
September months before the movie's
release and Ray was not included to
avoid revealing a cleat a key plot line
that she takes on kylo Ren and joins the
Rebel Alliance
a spokesperson for Hasbro
you know that is which you know [ __ ]
oh come on man you could put ray was on
the posters right was in the first
trailer how does including the figure
reveal anything beyond there's a girl in
this movie unless the like well we had a
figure of her fighting kylo Ren as one
giant figure just making single pieces
you're fine it is it's unconscionable at
this point I'm not saying like this is a
travesty like in one of the remember the
character in the prequels but come on
this is a game usually not for all ages
got to be certain age to play monopoly
cuz involves money I guess you gotta
have some brains can't you right it's
not like a bit of math it's a little
enough to be like five and up or subsidy
it's not hungry hippo its monopoly this
this is a game that everybody plays yeah
both genders like it's crits even more
than Hasbro missing it I'm surprised at
Lucasfilm missed it because Lucasfilm
needs to ratify and sign off on
everything that's licensed with a Star
Wars thing on it yeah ultimately
somebody there had to be like I know
that's totally fine maybe they didn't
realize like I'm sure a ray piece will
come later on how it happens is so weird
but I mean I get it I understand like
you but you have as people in positions
of power you know make plastic for a
living these pushing plastic people for
11:00 and stuff and they know their job
not saying they don't but it's like
they're going from this conventional
common wisdom like years of experience
like oh girl wants to buy how do you
know unless you force it down the throat
like you force 18 versions of Batman
down my throat like yeah and these guys
had to have seen this coming from the
way the community responded to there
being no Black Widow figures after the I
mean come on
guys there's not the first time we've
had to do this doesn't he can't be
sitting there going wait a second what
it's a trap
other joiners so you know it's not the
end of the world but it's it's
missed opportunity like it's money on
the table there it is money on the table
why would you not want to sell the 51%
of the population
yeah and Disney you know what princesses
do for you right she's in general now
but technically you got a space princess
just wait a minute that's why they kept
throwing in those princess comments and
force awakens like Disney leaning on JJ
gone she's a princess it's like she's a
general now like I mentioned British
once upon a time yes a princess that's
how we sell the toy you know it's just
you know you want here you want to make
everybody happy
recall it jam a ray in there send it
back in the world you'll get a huge
press influx yep and you'll get a bunch
of customers going well now I'm buying
it and they weren't even gonna buy it
last time there that's free your
insidious but we'll give it to you
moving on in the toy news yes whatever
god toys mark like a broadcaster for
Misha toys mark toys are what every
child dreams of no toys lead our news
this week because toys are starting to
be spoilers in the movie community
toilers if you will to Euler because
basically ya up Corning that phrase
right now yeah man copyright cash tag
fat man on bat Oilers toilers are
happening left and right mark because
you gotta sell a toy months before the
movie comes down so they've got to put
together a catalog like the diamonds
triggers catalog or something like the
diamond select or makers guys we do all
our toys with they put like pictures the
figures in six months before they're
even yeah remotely done you gotta I mean
like Toy Fair is in what January which
is always like four or five six months
before these movies are coming out and
it used to be no big deal you go to Toy
Fair and you'd be like holy crap that's
what that's gonna look like this is
great but in the age of the internet man
somebody's like and then puts it online
and billion dollar franchise gets
spoiled and you can't measure the effect
yet you don't know does it increased as
a decrease interest what have you but no
you know publicly-traded movie studio
wants to play that game they want
control
everything up until the last possible
minute so the idea of like this toy just
spoiled the whole movie is really
irritating one that not a problem
apparently such a problem that they
there is a Funko pop and Lego and a
German Lego catalog may have spoiled a
big part of civil war now if you don't
want to go to two-shot because I don't
hate better you better be on the hook
for this if you don't want to know
get out now do it just as your pause
fast-forward jump ahead yeah minute
ahead from now corn to these toys and
you know this is not a huge spoiler
I think but some people would be like I
wanted to be surprised you're fat if you
know anything about this character then
you know what will happen to this carrot
I was shocked didn't do it the first one
but I was like oh they're saving what
are you doing a sequel mm-hm
the character of ant-man in the comics
has also been Jai ant-man as well so
they're saying with toys that ant-man is
gonna become giant man in civil war like
you already had my money but could you
imagine that
just like awesome he reached down there
some concept art what we're looking at
right here is like talking about
Troodon there's a scene where ant-man's
on him yeah where's like Hawkman does
the a man riding the bow and arrow
Hawkeye okay so we'll get to that mimic
show the guy who helps the amazing
ant-man do something the other guy bow
and arrow boy he shows up again as well
Renner if we're lucky
what they're not showing us in the
trailer is Hawkeye gets killed in the
middle of the Civil War by kylo Ren put
them all together man like that Lego
game that's all and there it is look at
that toy that's from the German catalog
look at the giant giant man so ant-man
goes pretty and just gets big in Civil
War if they did that it's so smart man
yep I thought they'd hold it for ant-man
- mmm today I'm into they get to go
micro and they get the hill fine you
know the wasp
oh come on but so there man their toys
are spoiling it we know something cool
is about to happen it's civil war that
we didn't know otherwise
no it's glad I know it speaking of
toilers we've also got one for dawn of
justice the hell of a segue right there
huh that's right and the toilers have
even affected the DC Universe does the
Marvel Universe everybody gets a piece
there what is the movie called the dawn
of Justice B vs Batman V Superman dawn
of Justice which is coming and all over
your face neck and chest in March this
show is called fat man on Batman so
obviously we're very excited about the
prospect I know a little bit but I
haven't seen the movie yet but I hope to
very soon but I there's a special coming
up mark this CW special there Juna -
half hours on January 19th 1st half hour
is a look at legends of tomorrow a
fantastic new show that they've done a
me and Mark will be talking about that
we saw it yeah boy do we see the [ __ ]
out of it it's amazing
tune in like a couple weeks but not half
hours all about that behind the scenes
it's a second half hour they're doing
this thing I've never this crazy it's
called I don't know what it's officially
called but essentially it's a DC
Universe movie special so they're going
like we're right so the like we're
starting our movie universe so let's put
something on TV for like my mom who's
just like what Batman's fighting
Superman I thought they were
Superfriends so there's this like primer
that kind of shows you this is Batman V
Superman weren't using Wonder Woman for
the first time here's some footage of
Wonder Woman exclusive footage they're
gonna show exclusive footage Batman V
Superman behind the scenes stuff and
then the whole thing ends with the world
premiere of The Suicide Squad trailer
the second Suicide Squad trailer really
the first official one because the San
Diego Comic Con 1 got forced out right
this is the first visual one which I've
seen and it's phenomenal so to kick open
the doors of their movie universe they
did this thing we're like we're going to
take a half hour of TV time because we
own a network we got one of those and we
got an audience that's tuned into like
heroes and [ __ ] like that but it
reminded me of go to to chef it reminded
me of like when I was a kid
and this wasn't line one there's no 90
so and that much of a kid but when
Batman Returns came out they did a
special on TV
it was called the cat the bat and the
penguin and it was a behind-the-scenes
special where they introduced the
characters and like Bond scenes footage
and clips of the trailer but our member
was hosted by Robert Urich which is of
course Spenser for hire who had nothing
to do with that movie like I'm Austin
going like I wonder if Bob York pops up
as a cop or something he had nothing to
do with it just got a recognizable
person on who was willing to do it yes
years later dude
i am bob uric like I was sitting there
hosting the show about movies I had
nothing to do it then I'm like goddammit
I'm the new Bob here so does that make
me Huck
Spencer fire returns in 2016
Spencer Hawk man come on my show and I'm
done
a man called a man go hawk gonna be
amazing
hey that's some deep cuts if you used to
lots of time so right now she's getting
spoiled left and right man even includes
Batman V Superman a toy a toy
what yes has once again spoiled
everybody's good time [ __ ] toys
Mattel Toys have spoilers for Lex Luthor
and Batman now let's look at this and
see if there are spoilers store this
picture up gentleman right there there
seemed to indicate that Batman who looks
like he does in the movie posters
Superman it looks like he does in the
movie posters and the artwork we've seen
in the trailer will fight a Lex Luthor
that's dressed in not just a battle
armor but purple and green that hones
back to the old bald Lex Luthor suit
from like the Super Friends and stuff
there's a better shot of it now let's be
fair that Batman he doesn't appear
exactly like that in the movie a little
too blue and Superman like you know he
can't really he doesn't have like winter
variants Superman costume has at this
point is underwear on the outside or
underwear on the inside bikini briefs so
could be a farm so this middle thing
this this Lex Luthor armor thing that
could be a spoiler or it also could be
absolutely nothing it could just be that
selling at Jessie eyes
bergdahl isn't gonna move hope you got a
dollop Luther in some fashion feel like
how do we move this isn't this a Mark
Zuckerberg figure give a battle armor
like what about Wonder Woman like don't
make that figure are you crazy
come on they're not even making rays
like though that movie did you see what
he and they made a lot of money like we
can only dream nobody wants those it is
it's I don't know if that's a spoiler
because we've seen when they do movie
figures sometimes they're like this and
it had nothing like we have to figure
out a way to get you know an 11-year old
boy to want to buy a Luther figure how
else do you do that besides like well
he's got his special collectible kids on
and it's super awesome straggly hair
yeah you don't want to try the approach
of like well he's really going for it
this time kids like Eisenberg's reaching
deep fine his inner Luther so he's he
always gives and then this time his
performance he's going all the way kids
like put him in armor alright I just
want the throwback Gene Hackman doll
know cuz you can put him in armor as
well if somebody makes me - Otis doll I
will buy that happily you know what I'm
saying a Ned Beatty because then you
don't even have to just play Superman
you could play deliverance as well
squeal like a pig before Zod and squeal
like a pig as long as when you pull the
ring on its back you place that little
string string it's gotta be done in here
near noon so so there's another image
let's look at this other image real
quick man the another potential spoiler
figures yes this is saying that Batman
has kryptonite gauntlets so in order to
fight Superman he puts on some gold you
know emerald kryptonite gloves now is
that a spoiler because look he's wearing
an outfit we know for a fact he's never
gonna wear and it's studio 54 oh
absolutely man it's fabulous man call it
assault it's really beige man you know
but anyway
burnt sienna man doesn't necessarily it
doesn't really mean that
happens in the movie doesn't mean but if
he's fighting Superman I'm sure
kryptonite's involved somewhere right I
mean you see some kryptonite in that
first trailer yeah she the glow of green
so maybe Batman makes gloves out of it
it cost him a fortune
1 kryptonite bullet Superman's done mark
millar told me that years ago mm-hmm he
was just like you know why Superman is
difficult to write and I was like why he
was just like 1 kryptonite bullet and
you never have to tell the story again
he's too powerful and he's too weak at
the same time huh interesting concept
well done he's a smart writer very
successful too I know he does things I
remember at the time thinking what do
you know where you're gonna go in life
now look at him yeah called up the other
day is that can I work on Kings man
music [ __ ] off all right man so toy
people yes keep it in your pants stop
with the toilers copyright Kevin mark
toilers stop it up to oilers quit
playing in mind games yeah hey do you
know who showed up on Gotham tell me
well according to some pictures from the
set pee-wee Herman get out of here
Ruben's
I know you are but what am I Wow Rubens
showing up to play I would only imagine
Penguins father yes which he played once
before in ooh in the animated series no
Batman Returns not so much of that from
our commentary track that's true if you
ever want to listen to the commentary
track Batman Returns nobody asked for it
but boy is it fun yes you can't believe
this was a kids movie they had a happy
meal associated with this from the in
the very beginning Paul Rubens and the
girl who was the waitress in pee-wee's
big adventure in the dinosaur they play
oswald cobblepot's parents and they you
know put them in the bath right so years
later they're doing a little bit
stealing a little bit out of the
Berlanti playbook I'm being like hey
this guy we coming back against Martin
look how easy it is and I'm sure Paul
Rubens is happy and I'm sure like we got
something to talk about that's happy
people were like hey I know what that is
makes them feel smart it's good
everybody wins nobody like this nobody
loses so that's kind of cute let's talk
about other casting things yes let's do
that
we watch the Berlanti Universe of course
and you should too if you're not asleep
really wait a good a two-shot don't be
don't be don't be a dick no watch the
flash at least heavens go watch me cry
over the flash it'll make you watch the
don't be stupid be a smarty yeah how
many joined Berle auntie's party
stealing from the best in this space
nobody steals from no book so that was
it it's some Robin Hood flash is a
wonderful show if you're not watching it
and this season they opened up ripped
open the [ __ ] of Earth too so they
could throw any character at us and it
doesn't mean anything
isn't that amazing yes like so they
could take like King shark showed up and
then they're like yeah earth to
everything's us to if it don't make
sense birth to so they promised you know
it gave us a vision at the end of the
season finale of last year the first
season of flash he saw killer frost yeah
killer frost is there she is
these are stolen shots I think from
online from Canadia grafts Canada grass
stole it we stole this because they
shoot that up in Vancouver there she is
man there's uh was Caitlin snow as
killer frost okay now we knew that that
was coming because we saw that image and
they talked about she talked about some
interviews I think but we didn't know
they had firestorm originally played by
Martin Stein who was played by Garber
Victor gar Victor Garber
and then originally it was Robbie Amell
whose arrows brother cousin Stephen
Amell he was playing Ronnie Raymond who
was half of firestorm
he got spoilers kilt giving his life all
of us demise [ __ ] selfish pics but
then Martin Stein was like I need a new
boy and he went and found a youngster
and a black guy was what you do Jackson
I think I think so Herman I'm not as
familiar with the character but
regardless now that's who's on legends
of tomorrow as a liar storm in earth too
though
mmm firestorm doesn't have to be who
firestorm here is an earth one also
doesn't have to be nice it could be a
bad guy
excellent throw up that artwork guess
what this is right there
that is a sneak peek at death storm -
Doh and that's what the real death storm
looks like man the darkest night
miniseries that looks like it's wearing
a skirt a little bit right he crossed
over all the DC books a few years back
you know there's Amba fight everybody
everybody was dead everybody had a dead
version of themselves kind of like
Marvel Zombies but more interesting and
that was their idea of like Emma and the
anti firestorm be death storm death
storm is coming dude Wow and on earth -
spoilers him and Caitlin are a couple so
killer frost and destro are still
together so it's pretty damn impressive
that and I guess the last bit of casting
news we could talk about of course is on
Supergirl
yeah they've cast I forget what's his
name as twenty men but we got a picture
that's more important hmm look at him
that's the toy man right there which one
the older guy yeah I love that actor
somebody tell me the actor's name oh
dude he was in the boys the st. Vincent
he was also the dude who was like
mission impossible with Tom Cruise in
the restaurant when two broke the fish
tank with the gum and all of oh right
he's that guy okay he's I like that
actor his name was such what broadcaster
like you know that guy good
that guy good let's go to the videotape
he's he's blind toy man and it's and
that's a get for that show just like
Victor Garber as a get for right now for
a flatte arrow flash and now legend
feels like it that's the sort of thing
that started I think with Battlestar
when they were like you know what let's
get some big shiny [ __ ] actors to be
in this like these big amazing like
stage veterans and screen better than
any nominees will absolutely help sell
what could be something ridiculous right
you know so you get your [ __ ] Victor
Garber's and all these people presumably
have children nieces nephews children
somewhere in their lives where the like
hey it's a couple weeks work I'll go do
it
a charity that's it man I believe he's
Canadian actor me so damn good he's a
gift for them as toy man yeah and I'm
sure if you would have told him 20 years
ago your plate time and be like you're
out of your mind clear and present
danger oh yes yes he was in he had a
career like mine it was all about the
90s and then you know see for a while
but now he's back this time he never
went anywhere man but he's always
working Sicily but there's a couple
movies where he was that guy Miami
bureaucrat going to have to and you
didn't know if he was the bad guy or the
better guy Roxann like he was always
like the lesser of two evils until he
became the evil well he's bagging he's
playing toy man man and reach Aaron E
what good actor
crazy dude if you told me like 20 years
ago the dude from the boys the same
Vincent which is amazing if you've never
seen the book I mean saddest depressing
it's about kids getting molested in
Canada it's a wonderful piece of acting
and gripping drama and stuff and
heartbreaking at the same time and it
was like balls to the wall Canadian TV
before like America was touching the
subject matter instead pun intended but
storm dark is what I'm talking about but
it's the fact that that it's happening
goddamn it man like there's white
Martians on that show yeah there's again
man they got white Martians John Jones
and her there's a episode coming up
called strange visitor from another
planet which is normally referred
Superman of course but it refers to her
of course it also refers to the Martian
Manhunter they're gonna kiss they
haven't met yet technically right like
she knows the dude but she doesn't know
that he's the Martian Manhunter no so
she'll get to team up with the Martian
Manhunter and still not know it's that
Hank Hank and it's kind of I mean it's
kind of cool they write themselves it's
clever I would do something where I'm
like they talked about Star Wars and
pusses but these cats are like now you
thread the needle you set things up you
see what's evil like on Mars I would
never go that far
because who knows a lot to know what a
nose like on let's leave him with that
think about it
harmonies could be fun could be better
than it is your honor it should be
Christ anal on Mars got to be better
than anything's better than anal on
earth I'll tell ya the Martian yeah
anything's got to be better than ale on
earth went right to Mars unbelievable
that's all news we got for you right now
man we're gonna jump off we're gonna
come back in a couple days and hit you
with more news more kind of fun stuff
but for now man that's all we got you
got anything I got nothing man there it
is
star wars Civil War dawn of Justice and
storms isn't it crazy like you just say
these words and people are like nervous
I think it moved stock card oh yeah it's
great time to be alive kids not because
of freedoms and stuff like that because
we're seeing a character finally done
right there give me a giant man in a
movie that makes me happy I got nothing
to do with it but I feel proud for some
reason right yes
as we should we do do this we did this
there it is we're Bob Urich everybody
you
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder